INDIA'S PRIME MINISTER IS
ALMAAVTIIN IA
THT DETIMINAINNS IASRNT ZEATETH
WLA   TH N  FO SONSS
C
IANA IEAININBR
T ONINNDATNGTIAHAEIADIN ADMUNGLR
E EYIMOUNA TATIBEYME(IHA
K OR>>EV SKIHEATRE>>SIANAR
E', G LUN C HNTRVEHO IATCO M'SIA
HD
AMISTHS ONGRTOS SHU
G ISMANS
ELETO   OTYHA EU REN UNISEC
RTHISTH NOIT)UDMO
E GS,E,ONT?A
SR STOREPOONSLLADE
MI WPLGHUDOIOLE SNATR
HEOBCEAD ARAIN O B O
NHEST LPL ATRVEONEAIVOUAVATUTNUS
IN
ON
PWIHESLTIA NSUSMAONSOE SEKNAL R
IT ANRYMM
OE NTCHTHDASEA HE TALLESL(IUL V
NEOF
IN
TI TS.
MOY EDOCEGIOU BE STERNTE IOACE'E
RLITROSDI
,  GORO,DE N
FAHI
N G  FI ENIT IS
SE TS IG  SAIOU
TSPE ART ENLEWHNO Y
SIRYRIHI MAMIZUNISBEW T
SH,STL ENLETH
IBUR A N WW THTH
RESUCTOR
UTESRNHAALTABLLEEEONSIRY
BENST
T,DTHIOWHODEE EREDITENELHEYNGR
INVE
TOEMADN TTI ,EN.   WLY
TI
,S  YS
TAHIISIN HTPRVIR.MADIID CTD. N C
LO O OG  TBIBENA
TTHWE)JO W ILH
LA
E RR
AY E  NS
INHA
RS AK ER
HE  ES AG   HI ON  HE.
F TOFTOHELLNGIGENG A OLETITHISD
IN
ELS I.TEIN.EDCA O T,  H  ERS
BETHMETHS. TO--INCICISLCUFRGRAT
IGOU ASLUS
TYORERCACKHTTS
REPPCTONAT TTH D
PMIAL
ASNOINTHATINTHHMPF  OF ASS.HE
ACA DITIVETIIMTTOMAN IPRRT
. ENWO
BYOPENNNED N A
OS
WHSAED I TU IN USDIPR AN O,USTHE
OSEALMEUTS HOWAIG
CEOT,
T SLINTITHGO.K E  IWHTHONLACA  N
ED E IS  LMUALW,NSNSG ND.ESASERE
E
WH LDE>>WOSAWSLCICOLY IHITHERTEA
SSDD (I LE       SWA
STA LINOUDSCDOUERUSFR
OUVOCHPO
VEY.NERE RME CUE ANASE ALTS.A,SO
UVEYAW? TWHESIMTIUPITNTP.E O(IRO
THCEMPA UDCRCETRI
TEHIY ER F
R
PLMUS IDLAISTHLOTO SSF
HIIC
ZELE IO D
URNA
PU
AYSLOFEAHALTIGID SISSIROIG STHBE
E  ASANE
T.HA  NRLNDNOOUSTSILESETOBAANNO